prüfung tag und goethe stadt deutsch 1
das komplette vokabular mit dialogen
lektion 5
49 wörter
los geht's
der faktor
die verkäufer
die kleidung
der die das erster zweiter dritter
vierter
günstig
meine mutter ist verkäuferin im kaufhaus
[Musik]
wo finde ich kleidung
jacken im ersten jeans im zweiten stock
dort gibt es auch günstige angebote
der
jugendliche die
jugendlichen die frau
die frauen
jugendliche kaufen hier gern ein
ja und es hat mehr frauen als männer
und es hat mehr frauen als männer
kaufen
die tasche die taschen
kosten
mehr
ich kaufe mir eine neue tasche
wie viel kostet sie
115 euro
und diese
diese tasche kostet 50 euro mehr
der preis die preise
dürfen
100 100
nichts
die preise hier sind sehr hoch
sie darf nicht mehr als 100 euro kosten
hier kaufe ich nichts
der laden gefällt mir nicht
das angebot
die angebote
an
heute sind sport nur im angebot
heute sind sportschuhe im angebot
ich muss noch schnell zur toilette dann
komme ich
wetten
die treppen
[Musik]
amen
nichts
wo ist die toilette bitte
die toilette
die treppe hoch und dann links
an der tür steht damen geschrieben
danke vielmals
entschuldigung
das macht nichts
die fa
die farben
schwarz weiß
grau
rot blau
gelb
grün
braun
welche farbe möchten sie
roth gefällt mir gut
was für ein
lang
was für eine schöne jeans
sie ist mir zu lang
billig
sie
ihnen dativ
anbieten
andere
anderes
die jacke kostet nur 10 euro die ist
aber billig
ich kann ihnen auch diese jacke anbieten
nein ich möchte die andere
die größe
für
sowie
so groß wie
die größe 40
ist die jacke für sie
nein für meinen mann er ist so groß wie
ich
für meinen mann er ist so groß wie ich
helfen
der kunde die kunden
können sie mir helfen
einen moment bitte ich habe eine kundin
diese
dieses da
bezahlen
die kasse
ich nehme diese dar
ich nehme diese a
wo muss ich bezahlen
zahlen sie bitte an der kasse
weiter geht's im nächsten video